you think kids are dumb yeah I think as
Generations go on they get a little
dumber and I'm one of those generations
for sure I think that my that migration
is smarter than your generation I think
you're right yeah see my theory is
correct we both agree with this Theory
Steve's smarter than me
[Music]
28 girls were hospitalized with anxiety
after playing with a Ouija board you
hear about this they said 28 girls 28
girls 20. they all have their hands to
get a big board also all 28 of them
back this High just or they just grab
the shoulder yeah they're all like the
shoulders yeah I think if they were just
in the room even dude the peer pressure
to be affected by a Ouija board is
hilarious what you mean you don't think
it's real wait what do you think what do
you think do you think it's like the arm
thing where like like if you if I hold
your arms down and but you try to open
your arms right now and you do this for
long enough yeah then you think your
arms are going up but they're not
oh that's real no that's fake is it no
but that's a that's a spirit going like
this oh is that what it is yeah yeah
especially when a Ouija board is present
you think your arms you never played
with a Ouija board before I've never
have you no I'm too scared yeah no
because Hasbro got some dark secrets man
yeah I heard each one of those things
are [__] would you ever well you
could you could just Boggle [__] that
you can make one with this just write a
bunch of letters oh no no no no you
gotta get the one from Hasbro dude
that's not legit cheapest way by the way
if you want the deals just draw a chalk
on the on the ground go to Walmart
um do a Ouija board with chalk I don't
like that dude I don't like none of them
oh that's [__] up I think so
apparently Walmart's making a [__]
delivery right now
this is so [__] loud yeah well dude
we we like to get the deals but then
we're at a business park so then like
yeah there's a lot of trucker and
trucking happening a lot of rebar I was
just chilling in fact well my my Lyft
driver today he's like oh I deliver over
here all the [__] time I'm like yeah
probably while we're filming
he's backing up the [__] truck it's
the longest back up right now yeah
should we just wait or should we just
talk through it this is very low
it's so close
it's almost like it's next door who
backs up that long so I'm saying where
is he backing up in let's get up for
rebarb in yeah dude rebar's long
little long bars
son of a [__] Gilbert are you a big Mr
Beast fan
yeah I bought the chocolates yeah how
much I don't know it was a gift I like
Mr Beast Burger okay we're back we're
back so you didn't so you didn't buy it
ready three two one we're back he's
flexible what does the hospital do for
girls that come in for Ouija board
anxiety that's a really good question so
so they like I said this is possible
anxiety these girls were fainting
ventilators oh no where [__] like that
way down wow what city is this season
this is in did I say Abu Dhabi Abu Dhabi
Abu Dhabi it says galaris oh that's in
New Hampshire they need liquid IV I
don't know I was like why so confident I
believe
straight off the bat a lot of people
think this is a hoax it's like one of
those group hoaxes where like oh we all
saw UFO together let's all have the same
story yeah do you need my full name for
the interview you know what I mean yeah
somebody's gonna crack out of 28. oh
yeah are you kidding you think and women
but what if they all believe it whoa
what are you saying
this means on this side relax that's
right not this side yeah dude and what
is that the dad you mean like now
they're getting statements from the
principal or the parents
no this this is the head of the the
institution doesn't really matter oh
okay yeah it's all good but um it
actually has no relevance system or
whatsoever that's a different hat yeah
yeah yeah no
um so Ouija boards
created in 1886. they have been long a
fixture in the occult damn 1880s I think
every one of us has a story from someone
else about a Ouija board but I've never
had a story about a Ouija board I had
this one parent I was we were in high
school we went to volunteer at a dog
shelter or something and the dad that
was driving us he told us like this
20-minute story about Ouija boards and
how he kept throwing it away and it
would just keep coming classic in his
house dude see it's like Jumanji I was
like I'm not touching that [__] I was
like no [__] way you don't call me
[__] dead with the Ouija board dude
you're talking that close in his face or
Jumanji how did he drive he's a great
driver 10-2 the whole time my mom played
for real yeah in front of you not at all
I listen well I guess I was around but
um her and her two sisters played and
they asked the Ouija board how many
people were in the room
and then it went to number four and then
come to find out I was in her stomach so
I she's pregnant that's only three
who's the fourth person
that's crazy yeah
Mom Mom two sisters and then me and her
stomach oh mom two sisters
I was scared for a second my all the
hairs went up on my arms yeah I was like
Uncle Larry who's been dead
look on the ceiling what if the whole
time Ouija boards are just the 100
pregnancy tests
all the time I do like the phrase
playing they played it because I've
never heard that phrase before Oh you
used it usually yeah but I like that
better because it's like you're maybe
you're gonna win something
a curse I don't know what you're gonna
win but it sounds like a giant
scratchers ticket at the same time
that's the right word summoned summon
yeah I summoned the spirits on the Ouija
board so apparently
um people who worked at the hospital
they say they see they saw three to four
children arrive after fainting
and then they say parents you need to
investigate what's happening at school
because our kids can't continue in this
situation our children have always had
good breakfast it cannot be said that
what's happening is due to lack of food
however
um
the principles basically said you're all
stoking hysteria you're spreading
unfounded rumors we don't really know
what's going on yet
um the school's waiting for medical
diagnosis to provide further reliable
information don't make early judgments
but they don't know and is this a mass
hoax and like in Colombia did everyone
stand up at the same time I'm surprised
they even allowed them in the hospital
and accepted anxiety ah what is this
world coming to this anxiety has gone
viral bro like you came into my hospital
with anxiety I'll tell you to go [__]
go out there you can get away with
anything
not here go there you're the guy who
turns away that lady who's like I think
I'm having a stroke it's like man I need
to get the [__] out out of here you guys
see that video no so he's like I think
I'm having a [__] stroke and she's
like in a wheelchair and she's like I'm
having a [__] Stroud and these guys
like hey baby you get the [__] out of
here and she's at a hospital emergency
room yeah and then they're electors and
then once she left like
that [__] is gone and then
um on the way to like leaving they made
her leave in an ambulance or whatever
the [__] and then she died on the way of
a stroke oh my God yeah dead serious so
she was right you know your body yeah
yeah well see that's she why would they
tell her to leave is she always doing
that she was like oh an overweight woman
on a rascal scooter she seemed like nuts
I think is what they were thinking I've
got a stroke yeah I mean the woman who
cried wolf it could be like she's been
she's been there every day for the last
six months again but maybe she was
having one every day yeah
yeah arteries can only handle
[Laughter]
yeah all these officers are just like
lady we don't know if you're [__]
faking or some [__] all right you need
to get the [__] out of here it's tight I
want to hire these guys no right that's
Joe that's Joe's Hospital dude that's
what we'll call it you come in here
Joe's like the first thing I do when you
come to my hospital is I say you need to
get the [__] out of here and turn you
away yeah wait no no no no I'm shot he
goes from what a [__] gun wound oh
okay was it from gang violence and
they're like uh no I got shot because uh
uh someone broke into my house and I'm
like get the [__] out of here yeah I'm
like wait so if I said gang bonds you'd
let me in yeah get back in here that's
right there's a hospital the hospital
just go out there get shot again in them
streets and maybe come back you get shot
right this time yeah and then if they
come in they're like oh I got shot
you're like are you a blood or a [__] uh
I'm a I'm a [__] and I'm like sorry we
only service Bloods yeah boss boss a lot
of rules
can't possibly be that bad if nobody's
dying from it everybody lives to tell
the story have you seen the movie Ouija
would you play with that demon Summoner
yeah I don't know man
yeah
let's open up some Spirits I don't care
if it's it's from Hasbro man I don't
trust anything that they make yeah
Mattel maybe but not Hasbro what about
Transformers what about Ninja Turtles
really yeah you trust them I know you do
I love Transformers have you guys seen
the like 900 Transformer figure that
transforms into a truck and then
transforms back into Optimus Prime
you just hit a button [__] oh yeah it
looks really cool
like 100 bucks 900 bucks bro some Legos
is like 900 yeah oh yeah Legos is
[__] like 20 grand sometimes though
crazy expensive but down payment look at
that Lego pirate ship that Joe wanted as
a child I want it she's like twenty five
thousand dollars Eagles got lazy though
nowadays have you noticed that recent
Legos are way lazy because they don't
want to be violent no they make they
make everything in larger pieces because
back as when you were a kid you had to
it came in like hundreds of pieces you
have to put together now like the ship's
Haul is one piece it's like really it's
pre-made it's like so that they they
make less pork beans yeah yeah are kids
just Dumber these days
they're sick of the kids putting the
Legos up their nose is that what they
need bigger you think kids are dumb yeah
I think as Generations go on they get a
little dumber and I'm one of those
generations for sure I think that my
generation is smarter than your
generation I think you're right yeah you
see my theory is correct we both agree
with this Theory thank you
Steve's smarter than me I'm smarter than
Nick
how do you spell Luigi agree with me
o-u-i-g-i or j i o u i j icon man did he
spell it right that I don't think that's
spilled I thought it was with a Q oh is
it not is it or it just looks like a
cube it's q e w g i i what the [__]
silent my generation first three letters
are silent yeah first first five
constants are silence
too many consonants in that you have a
moment of silence before you say the
word
I could never do Lego playsets because I
could never figure them out
you never even just built random stuff
using the pieces no because I am not
creative or imaginative
shelves are hard
but I'm smarter than Nick yeah
just wanted to point out there have you
guys done the Bloody Mary thing yeah man
that [__] haunted me for three years
straight dude that work what happened I
started having insomnia when I was in
elementary school because we did Bloody
Mary and then at night I was like that
[__] didn't come right now into the
bathroom
but now I'm cursed because I did it yeah
so now every [__] night I had to like
I was like this listening to 102.7 KISS
FM a late night scaries yeah and I'll
just hit my bed like this like I can't
sleep Uncle Joe thinks he's cursed
because she didn't come
he's like oh no she didn't come oh no
it's over yep I can't believe she didn't
come because I'm a house the opposite
happened [__] she followed me oh wait
Bloody Mary's flawed though because
don't you have to be alone in the house
no you do it in front of a bathroom
mirror in the dark for 10 times yeah 10.
but then you have to be alone right well
maybe that's why I [__] up because I
did it with my friend because I was too
scared to do it by myself and this is
where I think a troll came up with
Bloody Mary
you have to flush all the toilets in the
house at the same time no that's tough
how do you do that by yourself that's
not what I my Plumbing couldn't even
handle that
you guys remember that nope uh that
piece of information was uh not uh not
part of it we should try it I think
everyone got different versions yeah
definitely different versions
[Music]
thank you
foreign